also John late today Twitter placed a
fact check notification on a tweet from
the president about mail-in ballots what
about that and this is something highly
unusual the president sent out this
tweet at 8:17 this morning and I don't
know if you can see but at the bottom of
screen it says get the facts about
mail-in ballots if you click on that up
comes a message that says on Tuesday
President Trump made a series of claims
about potential voter fraud after
California governor Gavin Newsom
announced an effort to expand mail-in
voting in California during the kovat 19
pandemic these claims are
unsubstantiated according to CNN the
Washington Post and others experts say
mail-in ballots are very rarely linked
to voter fraud in the last hour in the
Rose Garden the president again went off
on the idea of mail-in ballots saying
that it's fine to do absentee balloting
but if you did it across every state to
every voter it could result in fraud but
five states currently Colorado Hawaii
Oregon Washington State and Utah all
have all mail-in ballots and there
doesn't appear to be any particular
problem with that now the fact that
Twitter sources CNN the Washington Post
and others watched for the president to
respond to that Brett